foreign
do any other species on other continents
move like kangaroos and if not why not
final answer
yes there are a number of creatures oh I
got one right away
kangaroo rat yeah yeah the kangaroo
right you might argue that frogs are a
little bit kangarooey yeah yeah
um
so I would just say where that's North
American
there are a lot of so first of all I
would point out uh four-legged
Critters like horses have a certain
number of stereotypical Gates that they
discover right there are ways you can
move these limbs that result in certain
uh
effective modes of locomotion based on
how fast you're moving
likewise there are certain
organizations of Limbs that result in
different kinds of locomotion see you
know the uh what would unite frogs
and uh kangaroos it would be called
saltation
Locomotion saltatory Locomotion which
would be so there let's just put it this
way you've got a bunch of different
parameters okay uh we yesterday on our
uh suet feeder had a creeper which is a
kind of bird I absolutely love they're
not very dramatic but these are birds
that literally hop up the sides of trees
and it's just very interesting to me
that they can do this and sometimes up
the side of suet right and uh your
poison dart frogs do the same thing
right somehow leaping up a vertical
surface that's even kind of hard to
figure out how exactly you do that
without springing off into the world but
and sometimes they do spring off
sometimes but but there's apparently a
way but anyway the point is look are you
moving across horizontal ground vertical
tree trunks
two limbs four limbs are you doing what
a rabbit does where you've got two power
Limbs and two
auxiliary limbs but they're definitely
quadrupedal unlike a kangaroo unlike a
kangaroo then you have things like a
Pangolin right pangolins uh I don't even
how do they move they're weird sometimes
they're on four and they're kind of
waddly like uh like a raccoon and
sometimes they're on Two And they have
this little like they're diabolically
planning things kind of amount of
locomotion
um pangolins pangolins that's their
African uh African and Asian there are a
number of different species yeah
um
yeah so here's um here's just an image
from Wikipedia yeah this one does not
have a good version of the walking alone
no and I I kind of love the um blue legs
in the background for scale that's what
that's you got a better one yeah show
the better one
oh that's good but I've seen many where
they're on to they're not brainy are
they no that's a really small head it is
really really small head oh yeah yeah
um oh they're like their tails must be
heavy they're like I mean he's like way
cantilevered out and he's not tipping
over
I feel like I didn't know this
yeah neither we never seen oh did you
see him when you're in Africa yeah my
bucket list
hmm
um yeah that's amazing actually the I
mean kind of their heads are so small
yeah they're really nice that's a really
interesting animal I mean as I I've told
the story before but they don't move
like kangaroo no they don't they don't
but my point is just back to the
question is
how bipedal are you is a question right
a rabbit is somewhere in this right it's
not it's quadrupedal but it's got two
powerful legs that spring it forward and
the other two legs are playing an
auxiliary role but then you also have
um oh wow oh that's sweet I'm so tired
I'm so tired
um uh you know Birds exactly birds are
bipedal you're like wait what are they
oh I guess so right but they don't have
like little ridiculous arms like
kangaroos they've got oh that's their
power that's their power stuff right
yeah the wings in the flightless birds
it's either reduced or turned into
flippers you know all sorts of things
happen but anyway my point is look
you've got a bunch of why the kangaroo
wallaby mode is not
much more common than it is a the
kangaroo rat and I'm sure there are
other examples probably not very many
but they're kangaroo rat's a clear one
in which that it has been convergently
evolved by another creature so it proves
it's a mode there to be discovered it's
not particular to the the marsupials
but
um why is it not more common uh
well there is
um I mean lagomorphs which you mentioned
you know rabbits hairs
pikas
um
are like kangaroos like I think kangaroo
rats
um really do Best by keeping their hind
legs in sync like you know by jumping as
opposed to by walking I don't think Pike
is too because they're weird Okay
and like like frogs also like really do
Best by jumping The saltatory Locomotion
as you say and when you see I've spent a
lot more time watching frogs walk than
I've spent up close watching these other
organisms walk but like when you see a
frog walking
it looks weird and they clearly are not
sort of in their best mode and this is
when like if you were a predator not if
my my frogs because they're poisonous so
just don't even go there
um but uh like that's when you would
pick them off because they're like
awkwardly going like well how do I like
this one and then that one like what
even am I supposed to do it's like if
you told us
now you just gotta hop everywhere all
the time with your legs in sync with one
another it's like well I'm gonna fall on
my face a certain amount right
um I'm gonna forget and then try to do
the other thing and then you know I
don't know what happens I'm struck down
by God or something
um how did God get into this
conversation frogs oh right frogs deity
got it yeah yeah and you would
understand yes
um
so it's it's it's a tough way to move
around because the fact is that a
landscape
um
often isn't actually perfectly made for
two feet to be exactly Landing right
next to each other and so The saltatory
Locomotion is uh it is is harder and so
presumably requires a particular kind of
thing although you know kangaroos aren't
all that many places kangaroo rats
aren't all that many places frogs are
everywhere frogs aren't Arctic but they
get everywhere on the other hand
um the one of the big plates of frogs is
tree frogs and so they're also climbing
and
the hopping they they have such a big
leap much larger than
um
a kangaroo I think per you know per body
length
um that they can sort of get themselves
out of whatever ridiculous terrain
they're in more quickly I don't know
yeah
um
my instinct says that there's something
a a lot of the trick with a macropod a
kangaroo is the balance of the tail
right so that's true requires this big
meaty tail which you know you see that
in Tyrannosaurus too
um the big balancing tail and the
pangolins look like yeah and the other
thing is
whereas not with the kangaroo rats right
well the so there's an elometry issue
here which is doing this at the scale of
a kangaroo rat is much easier than doing
it at the scale of a kangaroo and there
aren't any giant frogs either
that is true too
um it never works I mean there's some
kind of sizeable frogs but the big
amphibians were Manders salamanders yeah
there's still a few of those uh but
anyway the the trick with the macro pods
the Kangaroos and the wallabies is
that a lot of the energy is stored in an
elastic form from one the Achilles right
and so my guess is that's not all that
easy to accomplish yeah uh design wise
that there are a lot of ways that you
can you know break yourself with a
particularly bad leap and so anyway
you've got a clade that figured it out
maybe it's all maybe innovated its way
through that problem in some way that if
we asked a physiologist who specialized
on them they could maybe tell us but
that you need an innovation to solve a
problem before this becomes a mode that
Evolution can explore would be my guess
and it's very different in a kangaroo
rat which is so small that that problem
is much easier to solve
[Music]